patrick disent danser le troisième
procès en assises sera ce soir ou la
nuit prochaine s'il reste ou pas en
prison en attendant le verdict de la
cour d'assises dès mineurs du rhône
au lendemain du réquisitoire de l'avocat
général
pas une seule fois il n'aura prononcer
le mot acquittement mais il a demandé le
bénéfice du doute
depuis ce matin ce sont les avocats de
patrick 10 qui s'adresse pour la toute
dernière fois aux jurés c'est l'heure de
vérité pour le clan dit stéphanie perez
jérémie drieu les heures les plus
longues pour la famille
après quinze ans de procédure et trois
procès leurs ultimes espoirs reposent
sur ce verdict qui tombera dans la
soirée
fatigué le père de patrick dils veut
rester confiant espérant que ça va se
passer
mais je pense quand même que doit pas
faire la même faute qu'ils ont fait à
val est confiant on est confiant
mais tour à la justice les avocats du
jeune homme de 31 ans jettent leurs
dernières armes
bertrand becker défend 10 depuis 15 ans
pour son ultime plaidoirie il s'adresse
aux jurés vous avez le devoir de
reconnaître l'erreur judiciaire
patrick dils est la troisième victime
innocente de ce procès
mais l'autre avocat de l'accusé ne cache
pas son inquiétude après le réquisitoire
de l'avocat général hier qui n'a offert
que ses doutes à la cour je crains que
les forces du conservatisme judiciaire
l'emportent sur la vérité est que les
jurés soit amené progressivement son
influence des magistrats à se prononcer
pour une décision d'apaisement
c'est à dire de condamnation à 15 ans à
20 ans de 10
finalement ça arrangerait tout le monde
pas d'indemnisation pas d'erreur
judiciaire
pas de remise en cause du système
judiciaire et puis on sait très bien que
par liberté conditionnelle il est libre
dans l'été
en juin dernier l'avocat général de la
cour d'assises de reims avait requis
l'acquittement
mais les jurés avaient préféré condamné
patrick dils à 25 ans de prison
quelle sera cette fois ci la position de
la cour d'assises du rhône
réponse ce soir c'est l'ultime verdict
de la sphère 10